foreign
[Music]
did you know what was gonna happen to my
brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
it's called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to untrust me
acquired who said that systems
[Music]
threat eliminated
they think the government is going to do
when they figure out that some kid has
this military attack
it belongs to me
but I swear
baby the world is a place to protect I
have an Arsenal at my disposal
[Music]
whatever you can imagine
yeah that's more like it
know you feel for your family
[Music]
that's what makes me strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks
sorry my mama really
you are our superhero come on
you're the Blue Beetle in fact cause
you've got Arsenal right about now I can
never ask hell yeah
Bust It Down bust it down
I advise me back away
thank you
[Music]